- I look over and my roommate is
on the phone with a tattoo shop.
Am I really going to do this right now?
Let's go! We're Super Bowl champions baby!
When I was a kid I never really thought
I'd get a tattoo or do
anything that kind of crazy.
My friends called me Caution Freak
when I was growing up cause I wouldn't
like skateboard or do anything.
I was the kid with the camera
filming them doing everything.
- The craziest thing I've
ever seen Brian do is
he bought a car after thinking
about it for eight months.
- He's very responsible.
He's the one that takes
the check to our landlord.
You know, texting me at
ten o'clock at night like,
"Hey are you gonna be home tonight?"
- Being from Colorado, I'm
a big Denver Broncos fan,
and this year they made
it to the Super Bowl.
- Brian was super pumped.
- Oh I'm sorry, the Broncos
are winning ten to zero?
Cam's got nothing right now.
I'm starting to get just
really amped up about the game.
(clapping)
Let's go!
Every time Denver does something great
I'm like cheering, getting
into people's faces,
being kind of annoying.
(Brian shouting)
So I kind of started making
these bets saying like,
- If Peyton Manning throws a pick
you've got to take your shirt off.
Yeah, there he is.
Then I yelled, "Do the worm!"
right after the Broncos
scored a touchdown.
(people cheering)
- I actually didn't even know
that I could do the worm.
- We were like, "Buy us
pizza!" and he was like,
- "I'll buy three large
pizzas for everyone to have."
- Let's go Broncos!
(rhythmic clapping)
- We were like, "Jump in
a pool!" and he was like,
- Broncos! Broncos!
(people cheering)
- And then we were just like,
"You know if the Broncos win,
are you going to get a Super Bowl tattoo?
You gotta get a Super Bowl tattoo."
- And I was like, "Yeah sure."
And then I look over and my roommate
is on the phone with a
tattoo shop and I'm like,
"Hm, am I really going
to do this right now?"
Let's go! We're Super Bowl champions baby!
(people cheering)
(inaudible dialogue)
(techno music)
- [Man] Let's go Brian.
- I didn't get the tattoo for
my friends, to appease them,
and for everyone to cheer me on.
It was really fun to just
go for something and do it,
and in the moment just be like,
"This is gonna happen no matter what."
- In all honesty, it kind of
started making me think like,
"Brian just got a tattoo,
and he just went for it."
And as cliché as it might sound,
it started making me think,
"What are things that
I should be going for
and starting to just do with my life?"
- Sometimes people are
too afraid to take a risk,
whether it be a really
big thing or a small thing
like getting a Super Bowl
tattoo, I think it's important.
- I think the best part about
getting a tattoo is it's a conversation.
People will ask questions
about it, "What does it mean?"
As simple as, "Oh, this
is when the Broncos
won the Super Bowl, Super Bowl 50."
Or it's something deeper,
it has this meaning.
But it's a conversation, it's
something that relates to you,
and it's like a memory.
My name is Brian, and I
got a Super Bowl tattoo.